really a mix of emotions tonight after
college students express how they feel
about the vaccine mandate victoria saha
was on the unlv campus today where some
students were concerned they needed to
get it to get their diploma while others
say the vaccine mandate makes them feel
safer on campus
for many students the college life they
pictured didn't turn out to be exactly
what they imagined but are hoping this
new vaccine mandate will help bring
campus life back to pre-pandemic i could
walk around freely not needing to worry
about you know
my brother i have to worry about my
family my parents you know i don't want
them to get sick the nevada board of
health recently approved coven 19
vaccine requirements for all college and
university students in order to enroll
in spring classes some say it will make
them feel safer i wouldn't want to be in
a classroom with somebody who isn't
vaccinated and then they choose not to
wear a mask i've actually sat up next to
a few people who have been coughing and
whatnot and
i've had to just move a c or so
but yeah i definitely feel safer i spoke
with a student anna she said as soon as
the requirement came down she went and
got her first dose but not because she
wanted to i'm a junior in college i'm
almost done with my degree
it's unfair that i have to be forced to
take a vaccine in order for me to finish
my degree finishing that degree seems to
be more important than their stance on
the vaccine probably going to end up
getting it just because of the severe
consequences me personally if i'm being
forced to do something it's just going
to make me not want to do it even more
students have to upload their proof of
vaccine by november 1st this does not
apply to students taking online classes
victoria saha 8 news now
unlv has not come up with any other
finds or consequences yet but they say
vaccines are available every day at the
student health center and they'll be
having more pop-up clinics right there
on campus